So protecting processes from
each other and protecting
the operating system from untrusted
process code, same exact mechanism.
The page table, when you're running in
user mode, doesn't allow you to go to
any physical pages that belong
to the operating system.
It's really done through this memory
management that we just talked about.
The memory management
is important enough
that we actually hardware
wired support for it.
Typically, you have what is called
a memory management unit, or MMU,
that helps you take those logical or
virtual addresses and
resolve those into physical
addresses efficiently.
Except we had to go through the page
table then to access memory location,
you have to access page table entry and
that adds overhead.
So the hardware actually can store
some of that in things called TLBs, or
translation lookaside buffers,
that are associated memory that
allows you to do this
mapping fairly efficiently.
Memory management is translation,
and isolation, what you can access,
and all that,
there's hardware support for it.
So there's another interesting thing
that we should be able to think
about here.
So we have these units we call pages or
frames, and
we have this table we call a page table.
And we said we go through
a page table entry
to see where our logical page
currently lives in physical memory.
So that page table entry tells
us where in physical memories.
But we can have some other
information along with that.
We can, for example, have whether this
page that we're trying to access is for
reading only, is it for
writing, or it's for
execution only in case it happens
to contain instructions or a code.
So you can actually have this kind of
protection information on these pages,
in the page table entry, that can limit
the type of memory access you can do.
So we said protection sort of, now we
are saying there are two parts to it.
First part is, where in memory
a given process is allowed to go.
So where can its logical addresses
be translated to in physical memory.
But now we are saying another level of
protection is, in what manner can it
access, even if it's allowed to access
a given location in physical memory.
Is it reading only?
Is it writing only?
Is it execution and things like that?
So the way we do that is in the page
table entries we keep this information,
this protection information about the
ways in which memory can be accessed.
And that is also used when you're
trying to do, let's say store, and
the target address is write protected.
You can't do that,
that instruction would not be allowed
to go through by the hardware.